c'est en extérieur que c'est bon d'être
ambitieux mais mais mais il marche des
du des monstres des mers qui ont des
pattes non alors là on est très très
très mal je connais qu'une chose qui à
deux pattes les oiseaux mais j'ai jamais
vu un oiseau qui ressemblait à ça tu
parles
il sait même pas voler monstres des mers
va dévorer qu'un élan est ce qui
t'arrive fallait faire quelque chose
tout le monde fait le plus de bruit
possible il faut qu'ils déguerpissent en
valeur planqué la trouille de leur vie
on vient ici stanley il vaut mieux
rester ensemble
on sait pas ce qui nous attend qu'est ce
que c'est
qu'est ce que c'est c'est quoi ce bruit
infernal les cannibales mécanique
rester là le bar à nous à l'époque du
bon goût des puces équipent envie de
manger puis il s'arrête il faut faire
remonter dans le temps d'aller à quoi
vous jouez à effrayer les monstres part
dit d'ailleurs merci pour ton aide
ok mais imaginons qu'ils soient pas
méchant est ce que tu as vu les tentes
celui qui est plein de poils mais il va
tous vous poster
alors on se détend les copains il peut
rien nous arriver on est sûr parce que
personne ne sait de quoi ces créatures
sont capables pas moi je sais de quoi
elles sont capables